luke weaver in game two tonight yeah
three and five on the year four career
starts against the braves one and two
lost to them here no let up in this
lineup it's austin riley the cleanup man
now with 301 with 29 home runs having a
sensational year
as riley unloads deep to left field
there it is number 30.
a two-out moon shot
and riley touches off another one
against luke weaver it's two nothing
atlanta
well i think he was sitting on that
changeup a little bit surprised that
weaver tried to throw it in there inside
austin was not surprised he crushed that
ball a bullpen game starting with jesse
chavez yeah you see his numbers in 26
games this year he was the opener when
he came up at cincinnati did a good job
bookend walks keeps the inning alive for
the diamondbacks and josh van meter is
coming up
and popped up left side
who's gonna catch this rosario will and
jesse chavez with a couple of walks
through 24 pitches preserves a
two-nothing atlanta leader has the early
lead eddie rosario the left fielder
leads off the brave second
jumps on a fastball and drives it deep
to center there's room for jake mccarthy
it really got all of it but to the wrong
side of the field right to the middle
part of the ballpark stansberry swanson
now
holds it first swanson strikes out a
good change up there from weaver
strikeout number two for luke two ounce
down jesse chavez the pitcher
three fastballs takes care of business
braves bullpen parade is underway
pitcher number two tonight the
left-hander drew smiley
that was a cutter that he got him with
now mccarthy just could not hold the
barrel back
vargas swings the burst pitch and a
sharp ground ball right to shortstop
dansby swanson plays it true good throw
three up three down and the lead off man
jorge solaire leads off the atlanta
third
and there's an easy out right to win
lavaro vargas they retire solaire to
start the third ozzy albee's is the
braves hitter he flied out on his first
pitch tonight
swinging in a drive hammered down the
line did he keep it fair
yes he did
another two run home run this time from
ozzie albee's and the braves add on it's
four to nothing got a hang and change up
right there and again weaver knew it and
it's second and third one down now for
paving smooth
on the ground to second this will get
one home aldi's cleans it up a third
it's four to one eddie rosario leads off
the fourth against luke weaver
that is fair at first and a nice scoop
there by paving
travis darnell will base it his first
time the catcher tonight
lazy fly to center for jake mccarthy
and there's two ounces in the fourth so
darno one for two and here's swanson
with two outs
and that's where swanson's living right
now he struck out twice
diamondbacks with van meter kelly and
mccarthy coming up raves in a shift to
the left side the o2 on the way to
carson kelly got him swinging strike
three
curveball takes care of the diamondbacks
catcher
off over to first base got him
they just picked up josh van meter
van meter was more than leaning the
wrong way he was stepping the wrong way
look how he's about to take off running
so a good time for smiley to pull off
his a pick off move the right side of
the infield and the two two on the way
from smiley got him swinging strike
three
and a cutter fans mccarthy
here is so larry reached on an air and
lied out softly too short
driven a mile to right
that's headed for the seats
it's five to one when this guy gets his
arms extended it is frightening yeah
he's got some pop fastball out over the
plate drove that ball to right field
that was pretty marcus at second with
one out and back to the top and dalton
varshall
lifted softly toward left
another breaking ball swept away from
varsho he flies out and two are away in
the inning and could tell martay coming
up this is jacob webb he's been
outstanding he'll try to finish off the
fifth
and the first pitch on the ground that's
efficient one pitch ends the inning and
it shuts down arizona in the fifth
followed by andy rosario and travis
starnoy against luke weaver is still out
there
96 swinging a miss duval over three down
to right field he's homered in his last
two games in fact
short center jake mccarthy
is there out number two
strike call and arnold is out looking
and if that's it for weaver's six
innings at 90 pitches and we're not
saying he's completely done here we're
at strikeouts giving him six on the
night jacob webb is gonna go back to
work for atlanta after he got martay on
one pitch
lifted toward left down the line rosario
in the corner well he's a good
outfielder makes everything look easy
out there doesn't he sure does one out
david peralta has walked and grounded
out
in the air
left center
can of corn for rosario
he's handled two fly balls flawlessly
bases are empty so carson kelly got a
fresh start in arizona because
yada year molina's never ever going to
stop playing
and on cue he throws another one and
kelly couldn't connect tyler matick is
on lower third for arizona in the
seventh leg kicking the 2-2
lifted to left rosario going back still
back shy of the track circles off the
route and makes the catch one out here
the seventh
that brings vargas up to the plate
vargas swings at the first pitch pops it
into shallow center can of corn for
duval so take care of our show here it's
another lefty lefty matchup
swung at the ball up and out of the zone
and popped it up
who wants it it's gonna be dardo he's
got it and that will retire the side
matsuk gets farso to pop up haven smith
has the arizona rbi that came on a
ground out in the third inning
and smith swung over the top of that the
double play in order here's peralta he's
walked
grounded out and flied out and he
chopped it right off the plate
gotta hurry what a play by dansby
swanson
came and got that ball
quick throw good pick by freddie that's
a big out so now arizona will bring the
tying run to the plate now it's a chance
for jake mccarthy who hit his first home
run last night
fly ball center but no carry to it and
jackson loads him up but sets him down
and preserves a 5-1 lead let's see if
dansby can bring him home
swing and a line driving to center
darneau on his way to third they're
going to wave him here comes the throw
to the plate it's cut off
dansby is back
and swanson has his 82nd rbi
well the runner to third var shows
retired and one man to get
ground ball should do it dansby's got it
braves wins 6-1 they hit three homers
they hold serve